welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Guster this is a
special episode of the podcast featuring
Nathan leens interviewing Flo crello Flo
is an AI entrepreneur and the founder of
Lindy AI Nathan is the co-host of the
cognitive Revolution podcast which I
recommend for staying up to date on AI
here is Flo and Nathan man you know it's
um it's a tough time for somebody that
tries to keep up with everything going
on in AI it's like it's gone from you
know in 2022 I felt like I
could largely keep up and you know
wasn't like missing whole major arcs of
you know important stories and now I'm
like yeah I'm like like totally let go
of like AI art generation for example
and this policy stuff is really hard to
keep up with especially this week of
course it's like hitting a
you know fever pitch all at once but you
know it's I love it so I can't really
complain at all it's just um at some
point you know got to admit that I have
to maybe nrow scope somehow or just let
some things fall off I'm I'm kind of
wrestling with that a little bit which
which I think is just like a natural
yeah I mean you know I hear you I think
it's just a natural part of like the
industry evolving it's like imagine you
know talking about like keeping up with
computers right uh in like the 80s or
something it's like I'm sure at some
point it was possible to keep up with
computers at large and now it's like
keeping up with tech is just like it's
like okay dude it's like it's like half
the GDP or whatever right you're doing
all this in your second language right
this is um I assume English is is your
second at least I have an excuse yeah
second I'm actually getting my American
citizenship I had this interview just
yesterday wow congratulations that's
great I know it's not an easy process
although maybe it it's about to get
streamlined I haven't even read that
part of the executive order yet yet but
I understand that there is kind of a
accelerated path for AI expertise have
you seen what that is no but generally
there's good stuff being done in
Immigration like they're relaxing a lot
of visa requirements they're like
closing a lot of loopholes they they're
doing a lot of really good stuff yeah
I've been thinking of um just as kind of
a general communication strategy if
nothing else calling out the domains in
which I am accelerationist which are in
fact many and I think you know you and
are pretty similar in this respect where
it's like um perhaps the singular
question of the day I am not an
accelerationist but on so many other
things I very much am an accelerationist
and like streamlining immigration would
be one of those you know I would sooner
sign up for the one billion Americans
plan than kind of you know the build the
wall plan certainly and I just did a
right before this was doing an episode
on autonomy and you know self-driving
and that's another one where I'm like
holy moly you know I don't know if you
have a take on this but the the recent
Cruise episode I find to be you know
kind of bringing my internal Mark
andreon very much to the four where I'm
like we're g to let one incident a like
shut down this you know whole thing in
California that seems crazy enough but
then the fact that they go out and like
do this whole sort of performative self
I mean whether it's performative or not
maybe it's sincere but do this whole
self- flatulation thing and you know
shut the whole thing down nationwide I'm
like can we where is our inner Travis on
this people you know somebody has to um
stand up for something here at some
point totally I agree I think it's just
the natural order of things right it's
like I don't know if you know that piece
of history about when the automobile
came about there was this insane law
that said you needed to have someone
walking with a flag in front of the
automobile that's no more than like four
miles an hour right so it's part of the
process man it's infuriating I hate it
but in some way and maybe it's scope but
I made pie with it I'm like it's part of
the process you can't really stop
progress It's going to do its thing so
it doesn't really matter anyway because
like the S driving cars are not really
deploying at a very large scale and so
I'm like yeah you know it's not a b neck
anyway I I don't think it is I guess I
have two reactions to that one is like
it feels like they if they if nobody
kind of fights through this moment then
there is like this potential for kind of
the nuclear outcome where you know we
just kind of get stuck and it's like
sorry you know the standards are so
insane and you've got to be you know we
do have a little bit of like a chicken
and egg problem where you know if you
had a perfect self-driving car they'd to
let you deploy it but you're not going
to get to perfect unless you can kind of
deploy it and you know it to me this
technology is just a incredible example
of where you know the relative risk is
already pretty high as far as I can tell
they already do seem to be as safe or
marginally safer you know maybe as much
as order of magnitude safer already
depending on exactly what stats you look
at and I would just hate to see us get
kind of you know as we're like kind of
close to maybe some sort of Tipping
Point threshold whatever to get stuck in
a bad equilibrium
of you know never get and then you know
maybe get stuck and never get out of
that chicken and egg thing would just be
so frustrating I drive a 2002
Trailblazer that I have sworn never to
replace unless it's with a self-driving
car and it's becoming increasingly
difficult to um keep this thing going
you know so I'm like how long do I have
to
wait my other take on this is I think
Tesla's actually like really good I
borrowed a neighbors I don't know if
you've done the the FSD mode recently my
grandmother came up for a visit it was
fun actually took you know my
90-year-old grandmother on a a trip back
to her home which is like a 4-Hour Drive
drive there and then I did four hours
back all in one kind of big FSD
experiment I set up my laptop in the
back put a seat Bel on my laptop so it
was like recording me and recording us
you know driving so I could kind of look
at the tape
later and I was
like man this is really good I had no
doubt in my mind coming out of that
experience
that it's a better driver than like
other people I have been in the car with
you know for starters so I'm like
thinking through my like person life
like yeah I'd rather be in the car with
an FSD than this person and that person
and this other person you know and I'd
be definitely more likely to let it
drive my kids than this other person so
I felt like it was really good and then
the other thing that was really striking
to me
was the things were it messed up I mean
there weren't many mess ups for one
thing but like the few mess ups that we
had there were there were a couple in an
eight hour thing it was like if we
actually had any Mojo and we went around
kind of cleaning up up the environment
we could solve a lot of this stuff like
there was one that my neighbor who lent
me the car said you know you're going to
get to this intersection right there on
the way to the highway and it's going to
miss the stop sign because there's a
tree in the way and I was like you know
for one thing probably people miss that
too like let's trim the trees you know
and then there's another one where
you're getting off the highway and
there's a stop sign that's kind of
ambiguous like it's meant for the people
on the service road but it appears to be
facing you as you're coming off the
highway and so the car saw that and
stopped there and that was probably the
most danger thing that it did was you
know stopping where people you know
coming up the offramp like do not want
you or expect you to be stopped there
but that's another one where you could
just go like put up a little Blinder you
know to just very easily solve that
problem and I imagine people must have
that problem too and we just have
no no will you know when it comes to
that and again it's I feel like I'm
turning into Mark andreon the more I
think about self-driving over the last
few days no I we you on that so where
else are you um accelerationist that may
not be obvious as we kind of think about
um this you know this kind of AI safety
and regulation moment that we're in uh
you know honestly pretty much everywhere
man like I I'm leari like I used to work
at Uber where I saw regulatory capture
and I saw cails and I do believe you
know at the deepest level that cartels
and Regulatory capture and generally I
think it's m olon who calls
them extractive in institutions who are
just in the business of uh they don't
want to grow the pie they just want to
grab a little bit more of the pie for
themselves even if it actually shrinks
the pie they don't care as much as they
get a bigger chunk and I think that the
world is just rotten with thousands and
thousands of these institutions whe
whether whether they're private or
whether they're unions or governmental
it doesn't matter we just have so many
of these cartels floating around and
it's killing everything right it's a
tragedy and I I totally understand how
folks like Mar Reon would be they have
built such a deep and Justified hatred
and reaction for this nonsense that is
destroying
everything that they
immediately just the pattern recognition
immediately triggers when they see
what's happening with the eye they're
like ah it's happening again they're
doing it again it's like chill I totally
get it but this time is really different
this is really something special that's
happening not just in the markets not
just in the economy not just in the
country in the universe like there is a
new form of life that's being buth and
this is we're like a new territory and
we need to be careful right now right
and so that's that's where I'm coming
from is like I totally see that point of
view and I'm like regulation for sure
there's going to be gels for sure we're
going to screww up 90% of it
politics is going to get messy and
trenched interests are going to get into
play and it's all worth it because what
may very well be on the line it sounds
alarmist but I'm sorry like we need to
say the words may be literally human
extinction right and this is not some
tinf fall hat Theory there's more and
more experts that are coming around and
saying that it's actually Mar Recon if
you dig it up I'm sure you could find it
I think it was an interview from him I
want to say between 2017 in 2020 that
doesn't help very much because he gives
so many of those but I think he said
something like at the time he was
actually appealing to an argument of
authority he was like look he was saying
the same things he's saying today
progress is good it's just a tool and by
the way the experts say there's nothing
to worry about so I don't know you guys
don't know anything about AI I don't
know anything about AI they do and and
they're telling us there's nothing to
worry about that argument is not true
anymore the experts are telling us there
is something to worry about and now it's
just like oh arbitary like regulatory
capture no no it's not regulatory
capture like open AI was funded on that
promise from day one so if it was
regulatory capture this like one hell of
a plan it's like oh my God we're going
to create this industry and and and and
we're going to stop regulatory capturing
right now right it's like that makes no
sense it was literally the plan from day
one yeah that's where I'm coming from I
I I'm I'm I'm largely in the EAC Camp I
am in team technology team progress team
anti-regulation but he something very
special and potentially very dangerous
is happening so let's go back to your
use of the phrase a new form of life I
as you you know may recall am very anti-
analogy as ways as a way to understand
AI because I think it's so often
misleading and like you know I often
kind of say AI artificial intelligence
alien intelligence it may be tempting
for people to kind of hear or not
tempting but it may be sort of natural
for people to hear you say a new form of
life and understand that as an analogy
but do you mean it as an analogy or you
know I guess we might start to think
about like is that actually just
literally true and and what what
conditions would need to exist for it to
be literally true and you might think
about things like can AI systems like
reproduce themselves you know can they
are they like subject to the laws of
evolution um but like how for starters
how literal do you mean it when you say
that there's this like new form of life
in AI
I I mean it pretty literally I think if
you zoom all the way out literally from
the birth of the universe the evolution
of the universe has been towards greater
and greater degrees of self organization
of matter and there's actually a case to
be made that this is just a natural
consequence of the second law of
Thermodynamics there this amazing book
that yak people love to quote which yeah
I was going to say you're sounding very
eak all of a sudden it's it's a good
point it's called every every life is on
Tire right um and so if you look at the
big bang you know like a few fractions
of a second after the big bang it was
just subatomic particles and then they
ganged up together and formed atoms and
then the stage after that was the atoms
ganged up together and formed molecules
and then the stage after that the
molecules became bigger and bigger
because they formed into stars that
exploded and caus all sorts of reactions
and so a few generations of stars later
we have like pretty big molecules and
pretty heavy ones um and then these
molecules form into sort of like protein
and RNA and forms of protolife we don't
totally understand there's a chain here
that we don't don't totally understand
but there's a form of protolife that
formed and then life and so you can
think of like I it was just a DNA like
actually was RNA DNA nucleus of cell
cell mitochondria came into that and
then okay good we have a cell and then
the cells started ganging up together
and now we have multicellular organisms
and then we have brains at some point
like that's like a big de but we have
brains like on that great march to
towards greater and greater degrees of
self organization and at some point we
have us which with a little bit of
hubrid perhaps I am considering the Apex
of that of that thing for now it just
seems crazy to me that everybody is
saying like one this is totally normal
like we oh this is normal we normal it's
like dude this is qu quintilian of adoms
that are organized in this weird super
coherent fashion and that are pursuing a
good in the universe like what's
happening right now on Earth is already
weird to begin with right so people are
all thinking that this is normal and and
that's what it is and that this m is
going to stop at them right and they're
like well maybe we're going to get
slightly slightly smarter or maybe we're
going to get documented and I'm like the
you are such a leap compared to an adom
right or compared to a bacteria that
like there is no reason to expect that
there wouldn't be another thing above
you that is as much more complex or
bigger than you as than you to the
bacteria like there's nothing in the
universe that forbids that from
happening from a being to exist exist
that is about as big as a planet or a
Galaxy like there's nothing forbidding
that in the universe from happening and
from the first time now if you squint we
can sort of see how that happens and
silicon based intelligence certainly
seems to have a lot of strengths up its
sleeve versus carbon based intelligence
and so no I actually sort of means that
pretty literally it's it is sort of in
line with the march of the universe and
this is the next step Perhaps it is it's
significant and so um I I am hopeful
that we can manage this transition
without us being destroyed that's that's
what I want to happen does that imply an
inevitability to Advanced AI I I guess
you know a lot of people out there would
say hey let's pause it slow the whole
thing down and then you get kind of you
know the response from like an open AI
where they're sort of saying yeah we do
take these risks very seriously and we
want to you know do everything we can to
avoid them but we can't really pause or
we don't think that would be wise
because you know then the compute
overhang is just going to grow and then
things might even be like more sudden
and disruptive in the future where are
you on kind of the
inevitability of this you know
increasingly capable AI coming online I
don't think it's totally inevitable I am
generally a huge believer in human
agency I think we can do pretty much
anything we set our our minds to I still
rtion by the way in the eak argument
that like on the one hand it's
inevitable don't try to stop it on the
other hand oh my God if you do this
you're going to stop it it's like it's
like you got to decide here so
unfortunately it's not necessarily
indivisible I am actually worried as
much as the next guy I agree there is a
risk that we over regulate and miss out
on the upside and the upside is
significant and and you know if you look
like during the Middle Ages we
successfully as a civilization stopped
progress and in a lot of countries if
you look at North Korea they did it they
successfully stopped progress so you can
stop progress progress is not inevitable
and arguably it is actually quite
fragile so no I don't think it's
inevitable and I'm I'm hopeful that we
can again I want us get the upside
without experiencing the downside you
know couple I mean the North Korea
example is is an interesting
one you know if I was going to kind of
dig in there a little bit more I might
say okay I can understand how like if
things go totally off track then we
could maybe enter into like a a low or
no or even negative progress trajectory
you know if there were a nuclear war you
know then like we may not you know come
back from that for a long time or if
whatever Nast hit the Earth or you know
pandemic wiped out 99% like there's
extreme scenarios where it's pretty
intuitive for me to imagine how progress
might stop or you know just be whatever
greatly reversed or whatever if I'm
imagining kind of a continuation is of
where we are then it's harder for me to
imagine how we don't kind
of keep on this track you know because
it just seems like everything is we're
in this I would call it you know I don't
know if it's going to be long-term
exponential but if not like we seem to
be entering a steep part of an s-curve
where Hardware you know is is coming
online by the order of magnitude and at
the same time like algorithmic
improvements are like taking out a lot
of the compute requirements and we're
just like seeing all these existence
proofs of what's possible and all sorts
of little clever things and you know
scaffolding along the lines of you know
some of the stuff that you're building
is getting better and better is there a
way that we can like do you think it is
realistic to think we could kind
of meaningfully pause or even like stop
without like a total derailment of
civilization the derailment of
civilization thing like you could
imagine the most extreme scenario which
I am not proposing but you could imagine
the most extreme scenario which is no
more right you do not exponentially
improve your semiconductors anymore
that'd be crazy right but they wouldn't
derail civilization right civilization
is not predicated upon MLA like we would
do just fine with the chips we've got
today and if anything I think we have a
lot of overhang from the chips we have
today huge huge huge overhang right so
um I actually think it is possible to do
that if we wanted to and I don't think
that even this which I think is the most
extreme scenario would actually D else
ization we we are actually Lucky in that
there are a few choke points in the
industry actually more than a few there
is asml there's tsmc there's Nvidia like
all of those three are individually they
are chokeable like a regulator could at
any point grab one of them and be like
no more you just stop right oh you add
this cheap into all of your gpus moving
forward so we have a kill switch at the
very least we have that so if sheit
really hits the pan we have an automatic
thing in place that like shuts down the
VP on this right now that would be
disruptive but potentially less
disruptive than a rogue ASI so no I
actually think it is it is very much
possible these things all onun the table
and I I don't think they would be all
that disruptive so maybe that's a good
transition to kind of where we are right
now right we just had this executive
order put out this week and you know
we're I think everybody's still kind of
absorbing the 100 plus pages and trying
to figure out exactly what it means
what's your high level reaction to it
and then I'll I'll get into some of the
the specifics first of all it's an
executive order for now it is not law
it's it's very
early overall I am pleasantly surprised
not by the specifics but by the fact
that we're reacting quickly by the fact
that the the measures that are proposed
are not
insane like I was afraid of like there
there's a really good case to be made
that's like look we have a GPR in place
we have a a bunch of 70 80 years olds
goinging as they don't know anything
when they were born there was no mobile
phone right can't really blame them for
not really understanding anything and so
I was afraid that the regulation would
go something like if you install
Microsoft Office in your AI then you
have to make a report and like what like
so the regulation actually sort of makes
sense it's talking about flops it's
talking about orders of magnitude of
training so I I think it's a step in the
right direction I'm actually I'm
actually happy about what's happening
with this executive order now the
specifics look it's um the problem is
that it's almost impossible to regulate
AI in a way that doesn't have any
loophole so they're regulating it
according to number of flops and that's
that's okay but at the end of the day
and then then you get stuck into okay
what happens when you have algorithmic
improvements what happens when you do a
r instead of uh F tuning and like
there's just a lot of different
loopholes that researchers are going to
find and so I think overall it's an
encouraging First Step it's funny I've
you know there have been proposals
around even like a flop threshold that
would drop progressively over time time
in kind of anticipation of the
algorithmic improvements that's a you
know even a more probably challenging
one to to uh put out into the world
especially given you know people are not
um in general great at extrapolating
technology Trends or you know don't want
to uh don't want to accept regulation in
advance of stuff actually being invented
you know do so we've got this flop
threshold thing where basically as I
understand it so far it's like if you're
going to do something this big you have
to like tell the government that you're
going to do it and you have to bring
your test results to the government I
would agree with you that seems like a
pretty good start and 10 and also the
threshold seems like pretty reasonably
chosen at 10 to the 26 any you know kind
of refinements on that or quibbles that
you would put forward that you think
like you know maybe the next uh
evolution of this should take into
account I think ultimately we tiptoeing
around is the issue but ultim we need to
come to an actual technical blanket
solution like we will not
solve ASI alignment by asking for report
from AI companies that's that's not how
it's going to happen so again I think
it's a step in the right direction I'm
happy we're taking action I'm happy the
action is not totally nonsensical but at
the end of the day like we're going to
have to talk about the kill switch right
the proposal I just made is is one that
I see more and more talked about and
that's the one I would I would feel best
about you got to put this chip into your
h100s and the government and there's
like a centralized entity that can shut
down all gpus all all at once and by the
way it wouldn't necessarily shut down
every computer because your your laptop
doesn't have an h100 your phone doesn't
have an h100 like that's fine over the
long term MLA makes it so that your
laptop and your phone actually end up
with h100 but at least that dies us a
few years to make progress on AI safety
and alignment ideally we would then
automate just like reportedly the
Russians did during the Cold War we
would automate like we would set up some
detection systems to God knows how we
would do that but hey there's an ESI
going rogue like the world is really
changing rapidly assuming it's not too
late which it may be because at that
point God knows but you could ver
basically that would give us the best
weapon against the ASI we would have
like a gun against the ASI's head and
boom kill all the gpus you cannot
operate anymore God knows how effective
that would be because at that point all
bets are off if you have an ASI God
knows what it does and how it protects
itself but that would be what I would
feel best about do you have any sense
for how that would be
implemented technically like it seems
like you would almost want it to be
something that you could kind of
broadcast you know you You' almost want
like a a receiver on chip that would
react to a particular broadcast signal
and just kind of because you would not
want to have like you you know on
elaborate chain of command or you know
relying on like the dude who happens to
be on the night shift at the you know
the individual data centers to go
through and like you know pull some
lever right so do you know of anybody
who's done kind of advanced thinking on
that that that stuff is like you you
hear a lot of these like kill switch
things but in terms of how that
actually happens so that it's not
dependent on you know a lot of people
coming through in a key moment I I
haven't heard too much to be honest no I
haven't I haven't seen too much Rec on
that but you know I think the technical
challenge there's nothing in principle
that makes the technical challenge un
solvable uh like we already have chip
that can be broadcasted to for like a
dollar from space like that's like the
GPS chip there's a lot of chips and like
it cost have one on your phone and so
why not put a GPS like chip maybe we
could literally pick it back the GPS
protocol I don't know but why not put a
chip like that in every in great GPU
again if you have an ASI God knows like
maybe it hacks the it hacks the chap
before before you get a chance you know
it hacks the satellites that brast thing
I have no idea but again I think
pointing in this direction is is is
where I would like things to go in the
limit I think the basically and that's
like the most extreme version of this
proposal but like the ovsky a strike
proposal that's like you cannot
accumulate billions and billions of
dollars of h100s and build this thing
else we will go up to L striking you uh
that that's the most extreme of this but
that actually I think is directionally
correct like we this is going to be the
most powerful force in human history
maybe even in the universe you cannot
accumulate that stuff any more than you
can accumulate enriched plutonium right
we've got a we've got a forbit that
that's the lowest level possible and
that level cannot be the application
layer because the application layer is
just it's just to diffuse there's like a
thousand startups every where any kid in
the garage can build one it's got to be
at at a CH point and the CH point today
is the city CL yeah well let's unpack
that a little bit more because I think
that has been an interesting debate
recently you'll hear this kind of call
for let's not regulate model development
let's regulate applications and then you
know we can kind of have medical
regulation for the medical and
everything can be more appropriate and
like fit for
purpose and you know maybe there's
something else to be said for that but
yeah I mean if you're really wor worried
about tail risk it's like probably not
going to be sort of me medical you know
device style regulation of you know
diagnostic models or whatever that is
going to keep things under control
so maybe you could even do a better job
of of Steel Manning the case for the
application Level regulation but I guess
you know why do you think that give give
your account of why that's not viable in
a little bit more detail yeah I think
the Steelman here is like look people
are going to use forks to poke each
other in the eye that's not a reason to
forbid the fork like Forks are awesome
we love Forks just foring people from
cooking each other in the ey with them
right the problem is that as the fork in
this analogy becomes more and more
powerful the argument loses more and
more of its defense because ultimately
it's just a risk benefit analysis right
and so the risk becomes greater and
greater as the artifact becomes more and
more powerful so more powerful than the
fork an AR15 and so you know opinions
vary about that but look at at this
point if you look at the data uh you
actually save lives by heavily
regulating the sale of a you can't just
be like oh sell them to everyone and
just for people from trting each other
with them like it's an 50 what do you
expect people to do with them right now
in the more in the most extreme scenario
enriched uranium you can't be like you
can buy all the enriched uranium you
want you don't even need to fill up a
form which by the way that is all the
executive order says right now at least
f up a full can you please at least tell
us what you're up to um so hey you can
build you can build all the enriched
uranium you want um just don't bond us
with us with it please like we roll it
in this piece you can do it oh no that's
not that's not how it works so that that
that is why I think it's important to
regulate the the silicone layer do you
have an intuition for sort of How likely
things are to get crazy at kind of
either various time scales or
potentially various like compute
threshold I was realizing I I did an
episode with Yan talin a couple months
back just just in the wake of the GPT 4
deployment and he said we dodged a
bullet with gp4 or something like that
like in his mind we didn't know if you
know even at the gp4 scale like that
might have already been you know no no
real principled reason to believe that
with any with like super high confidence
that that the gb4 scale was not going to
cross some you know critical threshold
or whatever I guess I don't really have
a great sense for this I just kind of
feel like and this is purely like gut
level intuition that yeah we could
probably do like GPT 5 and it'll
probably be fine and then kind of beyond
that I'm like I have no idea do you have
anything more specific that you are
working with in terms of a framework of
like how you know when you hear for
example Mustafa from um inflection say
oh yeah we're definitely going to train
you know orders of magnitude bigger GPT
4 over the next couple years are you
like well as long as you stay to two to
three orst more we'll be okay
like I I just have no you know just
we're just flying so blind but I wonder
if maybe you're flying slightly less
blind than I am I am of the opinion that
gp4 is the most critical component for
AGI and that the Gap from dpt4 to proper
AGI is not research it's engineering it
sits outside the
model so I think we have the
capabilities overhang here
that can turn gp4 as it is today into
AGI into proper
AGI I think generally that's the case
for any technology if you look for
example at Bitcoin what changed from a
technological standpoint that allowed
Bitcoin to happen was the same
technology we had for a while and yet
Bitcoin Bitcoin took a while to happen
so there was this overhang and Bitcoin
whatever your opinion about crypto
changed a lot of games right I think
there's this huge overhang with gp4 I
think we basically have a reasoning
module of
AGI I don't know if you saw this Pap
that found literally just asking it hey
take a deep breath and take a step back
just take a step back apparently also
makes a huge difference I think there's
a lot of tricks like that that will make
a difference and also the sort of
cognitive architectural layers around
tp4 I think can bring it to AGI that is
also why you asked me about what sort of
Regulation I wish was put into place we
need to stop open sourcing these models
we don't know know what kind of overhang
exists out there I don't think L 2 is
there but like I said I think dpt4 is
there so L 3 if it's dpt4 level boom
it's too late the weights are out there
okay now you can do you can maybe you
can put strap from there so we need to
stop open sourcing this things I expect
my timelin for proper AGI to emerge
is 2 to 8 years I think there's a more
than even chance of AGI emerging in 2 to
eight years I I I think the base
scenario is things are going to go well
just for the record I don't think
there's like a 99% chance of Doom but
even if it's 10% I think it's it's worth
being very very worried about that's
enough for
me 10% of is dying like let's talk about
it please um so 2 to8 years 50% chance
of AGI uh she things probably will go
well except for you know civilizational
disruption there's going to be like
stuff there going to be crazy
happening but two to eight years and
after that all B off I have no idea what
the bootstrapping to ASI look like but I
I don't expect ASI to take more than 30
years so I expect that you and I in our
lifetimes are going to see ASI so that's
a a pretty striking claim I think you
probably puts you in a a pretty small
minority and I don't think I'm really
there with you when you say that you
think
gb4 kind of already contains the you
know the kind of necessary core element
for an AGI so I'd like to understand
that a little bit better I mean you have
a lot of people who will say you know
look it can't play
Tic-Tac-Toe I think on some level those
kind of oh look at these like simple
failure objections are kind of lame and
and sort of missed the point because of
all things it obviously can do but I do
you know if I'm thinking like does this
system seem like it has this kind of
sufficiently well-developed world model
or you know uh I'm not even sure exactly
how you're conceiving of the core thing
but you know for for for a question like
that I would say those failures maybe
are kind of Illuminating on the other
hand I'm sure you've seen this Eureka
paper out of Nvidia recently where they
used gp4 as a superhuman reward model
author to teach robot hands to do stuff
and I thought that one was pretty
striking because as far as I know and I
I actually use the term eureka moment
I've many times said we don't see yet
Eureka moments coming
from highly General systems you know we
see eure moments from like an alpha go
we haven't really seen like Eureka
moments from a gp4 until maybe this this
seems like maybe one of the first things
where it's like wow gp4 at a task that
requires a lot of expertise that is
designing reward functions for robot U
Learning robot reinforcement learning
gp4 is meaningfully outperforming human
experts and so I think it's very
appropriate that they call it Eureka
what do you think is the core thing you
know is it this like ability to have Ure
moments is it something else why do you
feel like it's there and and does it not
trouble you that it can't play tic taac
toe for the sake of this conversation
I'm going to define AI as uh a seed AI
an AI that can recursively self-improve
that's a much more narrow definition of
AI than most people use but that's
actually what I care about like can we
enter this recursive Loop of
self-improvement that puts trap surface
to ASI in order to get there you don't
need to play tcto you need to be um a
good enough and the world good enough
here is important a good enough either
software engineer or chip designer or Ai
and ml researcher one of these things so
something that can get you to Bo trap
and so good enough does not mean better
than the best human it doesn't even mean
better than the average human it just
means good enough that you can make a
difference a positive difference in your
own ability to get better
right so if you if you enter that
recursive Loop of self-improvements then
M mathematically it's over and yeah when
I see the nvd paper I see that when I
see our own experience with the model so
today we are using Lindy to write her
own Integrations and Lindy is writing
more and more of her own code I see that
even as as it pertains to AI researchers
and ml
researchers I my hypothesis is that open
AI is using gp4 more and more internally
perform AI research my not hypothesis
the fact is that Nvidia is releasing
papers that's like well not only can we
use it for AI research through this y
paper but we can also use it for chip
design it works super well we train an
AI model that does Chip design super
well right so we are starting to see the
glimpses of that kind of recursive group
of
self-improvement basically the the world
model question kind of on a side step
because I feel like at this point the
debate become silly for for people who
argue that it's G or doesn't have a
world model what matters is is it good
enough and so even if it just over fit
it's training set even if it's just
predicting the next to and and not
actually understanding anything I
actually really do believe in understand
like a lot but even if it's not you can
imagine there's like this many
dimensional space with a ton of data
points in there and it's good by
interpolating Between the data points
and it needs much more data points to
understand anything than a human and so
there's that envelope in that space
where the data points are dense enough
that it can perform right and so that's
called like the convex hole okay and
then there's data points outside that
convex hole and it does it does really
poly outside to the convex hole much
more poorly than humans convexo requires
a lot more density than humans to exist
right there's there there's multiple
questions which are one all these data
points inside the conx hle is is the sum
of all human knowledge GPT for today
knows more than you right I know that it
can reason better than you that's the
expanding the convex all thing but it
knows more than you inside that convex
all right and so inside that conve an AI
research that's read every paper ever
not just in AI but in math in biology
every paper ever and the entirety of the
internet is it better than a human than
a human AI researcher I think the answer
is yet right um is yes even if it's not
better like does the outside of that and
this is my point about the capabilities
of hang can we get this AI model to
through prompting through cognitive
architecture to do better outside this
Conex and we're seeing that all the time
we're seeing people come out to bed like
hey we have found an automatic way to
rewrite a prompt that makes it a lot
better we have found a way that that
people that that came out a few days ago
that's like hey if you ask the model to
take a step back and to rephrase the
problem you're giving it in terms of a
universal problem it performs a lot
better and that makes total sense
because the the specific of the problem
is is is it's probably not seen that
specific problem in its data set but if
you ask it to reframe it it's basically
translating the problem into a full form
in which it's it's comfortable with and
so we're actually getting it to grow its
convex hole like that that's my take is
um I think the convex ho is good enough
to get to that good enough point and I
think we can grow that convex ho and so
I think that basically if gp4 isn't a
cdii for still GPT 5 is one yeah it's an
interesting framing I I find your
analysis there pretty compelling the
idea that you know given what we have
seen from like a Eureka you know this
robot training or uh there was another
interesting one recently I think was out
of Microsoft I covered this in one of
the research rundown episodes on
recursive or iterative Improvement on on
a software improver so they basically
take a real simple software improver you
know that can improve a piece of
software and then they feed that
software improver to itself and just run
that on itself over and over again and
you know it kind of tops out because
it's not it doesn't you know in this
Frame work it doesn't have access to
like tinkering with you know possible
methods for training itself but it makes
significant Improvement and gets us some
pretty Advanced algorithms where it
starts to do like genetic search and you
know a variety of things where I'm like
I don't even really know what that is
you know like simulated a kneeling
algorithm like what what you know but it
comes up with that and you know uses
that to improve the improver and you
know this is all measured by how
effectively it can do the downstream
task it does seem like it's not a huge
stretch to say that you know could you
take the architecture of
gp4 and start to do you know parameter
sweeps and start to you know mutate the
architecture itself it it seems like it
probably can do that and I would agree
you know it probably does are certainly
just just based on what I do you know
with gp4 for coding I would have to
imagine that it is in heavy use as
they're you know performing all that
kind of of exploratory work you know
within an open Ai and so yeah and I
think to your point we are seeing enough
of these signs of Life across the board
in a lot of different areas a lot of
Institutions are like ah a little bit of
Rec Improvement here a little bit here a
little bit here it's not very hard to
imagine it getting to escape velocity to
imagine it going super critical and fast
on threshold where like okay now boom it
can really take off so and I've actually
heard multiple people from open AI say
that they believe and I I I agree with
their conclusion and they actually told
me that before I agreed with them they
told me that at the very beginning of
the year so before gp4 was widely
available and they told me you know we I
think we're like in a we have egi and
we're in a slow takeoff and I feel like
that's crazy or not achieved internally
well they didn't say sorry that like
basically were talking about gbd4 right
like we I think and and I I am not
representing that this is the universal
position at open but I've heard multiple
people from and all the labs told me
that we have a GI and we take so given
that okay we've got this compute
threshold we maybe need a kill switch
now I'm getting we started this
conversation with me with my you know
eak uh side coming out and you know
being like why can't we get myself
driving car on the road and tolerate you
know some reasonable amount of risk to
do
that now my other side is coming out and
I'm like
okay what else might we do right we've
got the AI safety Summit going on right
now in the UK I thought it was cool to
see today that there's some kind of
joint statements between Chinese and
Western uh academics and you know
thought leaders in the space where
they're kind of saying yeah we need to
work together on this like human
extinction is is something that we think
could happen if if we're not careful do
you have a point of view on kind of
collaborating with China or coordinating
with China I mean that's tough question
obviously nobody nobody really knows
China I don't think super well but what
do you think about that I mean are we
naive to Hope I guess I kind of feel
like what else we GNA do except give it
a shot yeah 100% And and there is emple
precedent you know everybody is always
talking about this coordination problem
it's like they've taken like the oneone
course of Game Theory and they're like
look we can't coordinate well like if
you take Game Theory one or two it's
like solutions to the coordination
problem right and and so the solutions
to the collaboration problem is um few
players in a very iterated game and
that's that is the game right now
there's very few players and they they
are in a very iterated game they're not
the best buddies but they are actually
able to agree on a lot of things and so
we can coordinate with with China and
and again to your point like what choice
do we have anyway right and even if we
do not coordinate with them again
there's enough TR holds enough of which
are American right Nvidia is an American
company last time I checked and so
there's enough CH holds that we we could
could actually very much not give them a
choice like hey your gpus now have the
chip right here um you know and so
whether you like it or not we have a
satellite up here and we can kill all
the gpus you know out there um and you
know that that wouldn't be we could even
just done right for big gpus by the way
to be sold in China like we've done
stuff like that before so no I I I I
think coordination is is definitely
possible and I actually think it's going
to happen I'm actually really very much
encouraged to buy we winning like I
think the SA side is making really good
progress there is rising public
awareness I think jingon is doing an
amazing work here the regulation is
coming it's mostly sensical there's this
sort of progress that's happening across
the board AI labs are investing more and
more in safety and Alignment even from a
technical standpoint the work that enic
is doing I think is absolutely brilliant
um so we we're making really good
progress across the board here I don't
want to represent that that it's over
and that do yeah I totally agree I would
say my kind of high level narrative this
recently has been it feels like we're at
the beginning of chapter two of the
overall AI story and chapter one was
largely you know characterized by a lot
of speculation about what might happen
and amazingly kind of at the end of
chapter 1 beginning of chapter 2 not all
but like a large share of the key
players seem to be really serious-minded
and you know well aware of the risks and
it's easy to imagine for me a very
different scenario where everybody you
know all the leading developers are like
highly dismissive of the potential
problems U but it's hard for me to
imagine a scenario that would be like
all that much better than you know the
current um Dynamic so I do feel you know
uh like overall you know pretty pretty
lucky or pretty grateful that you know
things are shaping up at least um you
know to to give us a good chance to try
to get a handle on all this sort of
stuff one last question this is super
philosophical I know you got to go but
how much depends in your mind on whether
or not let's say silicon based
intelligence or AI systems or whatever
might become or maybe already are or you
know I'm not sure how we would ever tell
the kinds of things that have subjective
experience you know does it matter to
you if it feels like something to be
gp4 have you heard of the world
Mo I think it's it's in Zen philosophy
in Buddhism there's this story that's
like like uh someone asked someone else
like hey does can a dog have the essence
of a Buddha if the Buddha is everywhere
and in every being can a Doug have the
essence of a Buddha and the answer to
that is moo and moo means neither yes or
no it's a it's a way to unas the
question it's a way to reject the
premise of the question and and and
basically in this in this sense it means
there is no such thing as the essence of
the Buddha right it's like the same
question as like hey what happened
before the Universe existed Mo there was
no before because the birth of the
universe was also the birth of time so
the will before only makes sense in the
context of the universe and so anyway
that's all of my answer whenever I ask a
question when whenever someone ask me a
question about subjective experience and
Consciousness I'm like Mo it doesn't
exist it doesn't matter uh it's it's
immeasurable it's not a scientific thing
uh and so move all righty well some
questions bound to remain unanswered and
uh appreciate your time today this is
always super Lively next time I want to
get the Lindy update and at some point I
want to get access but for now I'll just
say FL Rell thank you for being part of
the cognitive Revolution thanks Nathan